bref je suis nul c'est nous arrête
maintenant battu sérieuse j'en suis sûr
l'udc ait jamais rien dit je suis
d'avant là le breton et frédéric et
avait dit quelque chose
non mais bon c'est pas si facile tu vois
peut-être que jusqu'à maintenant
personne n'a osé tu vois ça se trouve
c'est pour ça que c'est en corse est
libre est ce que toi qui les a quittés
non pas frédéric mais je suis pas au
niveau je te dis ça fait deux fois avec
deux mecs différends que j'ai ne de
feedback super dont des effectifs pas
que répliquer les méthodes de papa
arrête avec ça tu as raison c'est ça
qu'il faut que je fasse quoi talus et
devenir le meilleur qu'août paris ben le
meilleur paris intra muros ou quand
quran ile-de-france même coco si tu peux
jusqu à montargis a dû à montargis
formidable mais non mais pas tout de
suite